hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in letter 89
Seneca is providing a division of
philosophy for his interlocutor and much
of what he has to say about how
philosophy is is divided in his own time
and culture is not particularly new as a
matter of fact it corresponds pretty
closely with what we see others saying
about the nature of philosophy
particularly other Stoics but he is
going to give us a few reflections early
on that are that are kind of interesting
and there's also a classification of
ethics that might raise some interest on
the part of people who know something
about stoicism and might want to try to
correlate it with epictetus and his
three disciplines are toll boy so we'll
talk about that in a moment so the
starting point of this is he says well
why should we divide philosophy and the
answer is quite simple
we're not the wise people we're not
stages we're not perfect intellects so
it helps us to get a handle on what
philosophy is by looking at the
different sub fields the division
within philosophy and so he says any
asking for philosophy to be divided up
you are requesting something useful or
rather essential for anyone making haste
towards wisdom that's going to come up
in a moment as well why it's easier for
us to reach an understanding of the
whole bride proceeding through its parts
but he contrasts this to other people he
says if we could encounter philosophy
it's an entirety the way we view the
entire heavens in a single glance and
that's being rather optimistic I mean if
you've ever looked at the night sky do
you really take in the totality just of
the tiny portion of the universe that
we're actually able to see from our
little window onto it assuming there's
no light pollution or anything like that
probably not but he talks about the wise
person the sage he says the intellect of
the wise embraces the entire mass of
philosophy and surveys it as rapidly as
our eye surveys the sky for us on the
other hand whose range of vision is
limited and it's not just limited
because we can only look at a certain
portion he talks about it being limited
by obstructions mists that we have to
peer through particular details are
easier to register because we're not yet
capable of grasping the whole and he
said so it's really good for us to
divide philosophy up into its parts we
just have to be careful not to divide it
too much we don't want to be so nice in
our distinctions meaning minut that we
end up just with a whole bunch of little
grains of sand and we have no way of
putting it back together so that that's
an important point then he brings up
something else which is again not
completely original but he's putting an
interesting spin on it he says that we
we need to understand that philosophy
and wisdom are not the same thing and
there's a good etymological reason for
this in Greek philosophy is philosophy
ah right and then wisdom is Sophia by
itself so philosophy is the
love you know the fellows philia in this
case which you know it does also mean
friendship as well but it's a desire
it's seeking out of wisdom so it's not
the same thing as wisdom in itself he
says that wisdom is the human mind
supreme good philosophy is the law of an
aspiration for that wisdom philosophy is
proceeding towards the destination at
which the former has arrived on he talks
a little bit about the etymology of it
and then he says a few other things that
are kind of interesting it tells us
there's different definitions of
philosophy some have called it a
commitment to virtue that the stoic
certainly can take that on others a
commitment to rectifying the mind again
Stoics can take that on others according
to certain thinkers it is the effort to
reason correctly important also for the
Stoics but not the totality of
philosophy and he says what is generally
agreed is that there's a difference
between philosophy and wisdom the object
of aspiration cannot be the same thing
as aspiration itself and then here he
has a very funny sort of metaphor he
says just as the desire for money what
we call avarice or greed is not the same
thing as money itself right and when the
avarice has it it's presumably satisfied
and it rests and it's good or maybe he
wants more money you know depending on
how a voracious it is philosophy is like
that for wisdom
so the philosopher is the person who's
greedy for wisdom and in a certain way
and he goes on and he says this is a
nice way of putting it one of these is
the thing desiring the other is the
object of desire and one is the outcome
the effect effectives
and the reward muniya of the other
philosophy says is the progression
wisdom is where it is headed so you know
that's that's good to keep in mind
philosophy itself we often talk about it
as if studying philosophy the philosophy
say of the Stoics we are studying there
wisdom but we're always studying
something that's kind of on the way to
wisdom
now he doesn't do anything further with
that point in this particular letter but
you know that comes up in other places
in his works as well then he launches
into this discussion which is really the
main body of the letter and here again
he's being totally unoriginal and we
love him for that because he's telling
us something about a traditional
distinction of philosophy into three
parts instead of distinguishing it as
some people do into theoretical and
practical philosophy the Stoics and
others talked about it philosophy is
having three main divisions they call
these ethics physics and logic and you
know you might say while they left out a
lot of stuff you know what about
psychology well as it so happens that
falls into the realm of physics also
partly when it comes to the emotions
into the realm of ethics and so these
these actually encompass an awful lot
physics in ancient times is not just
about what we might say inanimate
objects and how they can be shot out of
a cannon and the trajectories they have
or you know how the wind blows or things
like that it was about the entire
universe and all the things within it so
that's good to keep in mind and as we're
gonna see ethics has similarly wide
scope as well
so he tells us here we go according to
the major in most numerous authorities
philosophy has these three parts the
first of these parts
ethics regulates the mind it tells the
human being how they ought to live what
it is that they'll ought to desire what
it is that they ought to choose how they
ought to prioritize we could go on and
on and on tells us also what's good for
us then he goes on and he says ii
studies the nature of things how things
are why they change all of those sorts
of matters and then the third examines
the meanings of words
the structure of sentences the forms of
arguments with a view to preventing
falsehood and from masquerading as truth
and now notice there that he's talking
about a purpose behind logic right it's
not that you just study logic for its
own sake you study it so that you're not
going to get fooled and make mistakes
and accept bad arguments in place of
good arguments or believe things that
aren't true now did everybody accept
this tripartite distinction no not
exactly and those who did sometimes also
would reject parts of it so he talks
about the Peripatetic these are the
Aristotelian 's and he says that the
appear pathetic ANDed politics is a
fourth part because they take it to
require a special training with its own
subject matter so when you're talking
about politics
that means Society studying the social
dimension of human existence and
presumably today it would include not
just political science or civics but
also a good part of what we call
psychology and sociology and things like
that he says that some of the
Peripatetic have made the further
addition of what they call economics and
this is interesting now this is the term
that has come to take on a very very
different meaning for us in the late
modern age than it has through most of
Western history because it comes from
the word for for house or household eCos
and it basically means how to run your
household in a way that's going to keep
you supplied with what you need and you
know allocate resources properly it is
not about society as a whole the way
that we make it and economic decisions
within a marketplace it's really about
what you do in the household and then he
says there you know some of these
peripatetic stack about other kinds of
life as being separate topics and then
he says well that doesn't actually work
why not all those actually fit into
ethics they're not distinct from ethics
they're just subdivisions within ethics
you could say and then he goes on any
text about the Epicureans the epicurean
say well we're going to study ethics and
we're gonna study physics but we don't
need logic and then he says and that's
bad for them because when they found
themselves forced to distinguish the
ambiguities and exposed falsehoods that
lurk under the appearance of truth then
they introduced the topic they call
judgment and rule and use it as a
supplement to physics but what is it
really it's really logic you can't get
away from this tripartite tripartite
distinction all right so now we've got
two major schools of antiquity that are
now on the same page of the Stoics he
also talks about the crn ax now this is
a school that we don't actually have
many records of and we have very we only
have fragments of them founded by one of
Socrates students err stiffest we know
about them mainly because of bits and
pieces here and there in Cicero and
Seneca and Diogenes layer taste and they
actually said that they would get rid of
physics and logic but then he says
they'd have to reintroduce these in
another way why because they take ethics
and they divide it into five parts
dealing with proper objects of pursuit
and avoidance emotions actions causes
and arguments but the causes of things
in fact belong to physics and argument
belongs to logic so they can't get away
from it either you start to see a common
theme here don't you you know you you
you want to get rid of certain aspects
of philosophy but they are pretty much
unavoidable you you have to be able to
say how things actually are and how
they're caused you have to be able to
have some sort of criterion for what is
good reasoning and what's not and you
also need something dealing with our
moral and practical life then there was
a guy Aristo who was a you could say he
was an offshoot of the Stoics he was a
contemporary and student as Dino but he
said that all you need is ethics and and
he only accepted one part of ethics he
says that the you know this was not a
you know particularly good way to go
about things there's lots of criticisms
of iris no
you can find in other places so if we
accept this tripartite distinction of
philosophy which again very common in
ancient times you know we may say well
some of the things that we want to study
now don't fit neatly into this schema
granted but let's say we go with him on
that so sound like it tells us that we
can break these down further and that
can be quite useful I'm going to come
back to the ethics part in just a moment
he talks about the physical part of
philosophy being divided into two parts
those that have to do with corporeal
things bodily things material things and
incorporeal things says the topic of
bodies is primarily divided divided into
bodies that are causes and bodies that
arise from causes that is to say the
elements as to the topic of the elements
it has no subdivisions some people want
to divide it further into matter and
then the cause that activates everything
and the elements and and Seneca doesn't
worry too much about that he does have a
whole work called natural questions but
he's not going to worry about that too
much and this letter what about logic he
goes on and he says we can divide the
logical part of philosophy all discourse
is either continuous meaning that you
somebody talks and just keeps talking or
it's divided into questions and
responses and the official term for the
just talking about things is rhetoric
the latter dialectic and he says
rhetoric attempts expressions thoughts
organization dialectic is divided into
two parts words and meanings and they
says then comes a huge subdivision of
each of these topics and he says I'm not
gonna keep subdividing all of these
things but it is kind of interesting
that you see here that Seneca just like
Cicero just like so many other thinkers
in logic he's not excluding rhetoric
from and he's actually including
rhetoric in the logical part because it
has to do with how we articulate things
now rhetoric
one key aspect of it is it aims at as
Aristotle said finding the means of
persuasion
which means that it focuses not on just
making an argument to any old person out
there but on specific kinds of audiences
and how to reach them dialectic is a
whole other field that is concerned with
with you could say inquiry and so that's
all part of physics the ethics part I
wanted to talk about in particular
because here Seneca introduces a three
fold distinction again within this this
part of a three fold distinction and
those who know a little bit of stoic
philosophy particularly if they're
getting it from you know pure a doe or
from epictetus might be tempted to
conflate what Seneca is saying here with
the division into the three toe boy the
your disciplines the discipline of
desire the discipline of action or
choice and the discipline of ascent
this is not what Seneca is actually
talking about here so he tells us that
there are three main divisions to
ethical philosophy and this is
reflective of how Stoics viewed it and
he said the first assigns to each thing
its proper value and determines what
it's worth and he says this is an
extremely useful investigation for what
is as needed as putting the price on
things figuring out what is actually
valuable and what is from the stoic
perspective and indifferent and what
you're willing to trade for what among
the indifference how to compare them
against each other that is what that
first part of ethics would deal with the
second party says deals with impulse in
patusan latin or in in greek [ __ ] may
and this is something that we sometimes
translate as impulse and sometimes we
translate it as choice depending on what
sort of aspect we're putting on it it's
a greek term that epictetus certainly
uses it's a common part of stoic
ethics and so figuring out why we are
you know desiring certain things averse
to certain things oriented toward
certain things this is you know also
connected to the first thing because if
we can realize that we've got mistaken
ideas about what's valuable or not we
can also affect our impulses and then
the third party says deals with actions
and in the in the Latin it's in the
ablative octi ona Bush threat but accion
ace is the plural of Axio of the things
that one does this is the praxis or the
you know Prague Matta
in Greek and so these three divisions
can be studied on their own and
presumably if you were going through a
course of stoic philosophy each one of
them would be examined and dealt with
thematically so he says the objectives
are of ethics are first to enable you to
judge what each thing is worth secondly
to to allow you to entertain a
well-adjusted and controlled impulse
with respect to them and third to enable
you to achieve harmony between your
impulse and your reaction so that you
may be consistent in all of your
behavior and now he says one other thing
that I think is particularly important
here any defect in one of these three
causes disturbance to the others what
good is it to have made a comparative
assessment of everything if your
impulses are uncovered what good is it
to restraint restrained your impulses
and have your desires under control if
your actions themselves you're
insensitive to circumstances and don't
know the proper time and place and
manner of doing each thing so that tells
us what this third discipline is about
and then he says it's one thing to
understand the Worth and value of things
it's another to understand the demands
of the moment and something else again
to restrain one's impulses and proceed
with what one has to do without rushing
into things so each one of these these
parts of ethics is needed in order to do
the other part or the other parts well
so this
is how Seneca subdivides philosophy it's
not the only way we can do it but this
is you know quite a persuasive
presentation that he's making and this
corresponds to what we think to be a
very common division with the three
parts here and then probably a fairly
Orthodox stoic way of articulating the
different things that need to be studied
under ethics over here
you